after days of negotiation for the very
first time
my parents allowed me to step out
unescorted for a movie with my friends
i was 14
and beyond excited with this new freedom
i had
with a big smile on my face i entered a
packed theater
and just 10 steps from my seat i felt
these heavy hands
grabbed both my breasts and before i
knew it these hands disappeared
i screamed and ran outside
and i still remember those dirty
handprints on my white crisp cotton
shirt
announcing to the world what had just
happened
i returned home devastated
kept the lights on all through the night
and the outdoors terrified me
i didn't want to go out at all
it is not news that women face rampant
violence inside homes as well across the
world
so if it's unsafe outside
and inside
where do we go
women in india
are over 600 million strong
that's a lot of people but this is what
my country looks like the outdoors you
can count the number of women in these
pictures
and
there aren't any or just one or two and
this is by the day but this number
significantly drops at night you don't
see many women walking alone at night
because they're simply not safe
400 000
that's 45 women every hour face varying
degrees of violence ranging from
domestic violence to rape in india
a 13 year old girl and her mother were
gang raped on a highway just 45 minutes
from where my parents live
when i heard this
i just recalled the same incident that
happened to me
i was devastated
i found myself in the same hysterical
state i was outside of that theater
for everybody around me life moved on
we are hardwired to think that this is
just how the world is
instead of asking the fundamental
question of how wrong this is
i am here
and i am fighting
for safer spaces for women by increasing
their mobility
by movement of the body and mind to take
control over their lives
so how i did that
i wanted to
prove to the world
that i can face my demons
and not just for one but 230 continuous
days
so i decided to walk
across the length of india
from the very south to the north
a distance of 2 300 miles
2 300 miles how much is that
if you started from la you would reach
new york
if you started from stockholm
you would reach cairo that's the
distance that i walked
and mile after mile as i walked
it became very apparent
that women's lack of mobility
hinders their freedom to earn an income
and exert any form of independence
on my long walk
i wanted to understand
what
made india one of the most unsafe
countries in the world
i was determined to meet the women who
were facing challenges around their
safety
and above all i wanted to understand if
the situation is beyond repair
so i walked through 170 cities
small towns and villages and i met over
85 000 women
in small huddles to like large crowds
this is a workshop this is with women of
an organization and in small huddles
inside their homes
and that's when i realized that mobility
plays a very very big role
in their freedom to pursue anything
outside of their homes
when i was walking across the country
in my conversations with these women
i was talking to them about different
topics
and
this ranged from
being financial independent
to
taking defensive positions in times of
physical assault
this is an activity we did where we want
to anchor ourselves and find our ground
and if somebody comes you push or just
feel stronger
what it feels in your body to be
stronger
and most of the times our discussions
were around finding your voice
[Music]
i wanted women to move with their bodies
and to shift their minds
the media amplified our cause and
reported with new energy
on a demand for a safer country for
women
on my long walk
i met so many people
and
most of the times
i noticed that
marriage in india is treated a little
differently from rest of the world you
see
marriage means a woman becomes the
property of her husband and his family
and not being able to step outside to
pursue an education a job or create a
community of our own
that lack of mobility both social and
physical
that is what reflects the state of
gender inequality
in our society
on my long walk i bore witness to
chilling violent incomprehensible human
behavior
but at the same time i met brave women
survivors of atrocious crimes who lit my
path
with their unbelievable strength to
carry on
and then something miraculous happened
i met this woman named jaya bharti
on her motorcycle she arrived in the
same village i was in
and she was there at a training camp
teaching other women how to ride
scooters
i had never seen anything like this
before
she dawned the narrative of being fierce
the odd one out smashing patriarchy
every single time she rode her
motorcycle she was an inspiration for
all women young and old
and at the training camp i saw how
revving a motorbike and holding a
steering wheel didn't give these women
the ability to drive but that much
needed control
over their lives and i knew instantly
that
having women take charge and create
change for themselves is the only way
to transform our broken systems
it got me thinking
what if we could get communities of
women moving
actually physically moving away from the
house
that would open a window
where they could move psychologically
where they could understand or realize
that she could step out of bad
situations
and have the ability to do it
this way we would have more women feel
safe and confident
so jeb bharti and i the we both decided
that we are going to join forces
and create a movement exclusively for
women
focused on mobility
we have set up a system
where a woman can train to drive for
themselves or for ubers taxis or just
become delivery agents for amazon and
other big companies or local businesses
that's money in the bank
and the freedom and the psychological
you know know that i can step outside of
my home
we are connecting these women drivers on
a national network where they can reach
out to each other for support and to
share experiences and not just that she
can actually ping another driver in her
vicinity
if she is feeling distressed
if she's in danger or if she's simply
just waiting for her next ride or pick
up and doesn't want to wait alone
for us receiving our first paycheck
might be very empowering but for 59 year
old naga money that moment arrived when
she put her scooter on a center stand
and
feeling physically strong and proving to
the society that she's beyond being just
a sidekick
we have trained 1800 women
who are road ready
and raring
road ready and raring to go and our
decade-long mission is to bring one
million women into mobility
and be the largest network of women
drivers connected to each other
by rethinking mobility for women
giving them a safe transport and safety
outside of home it is our hope to
transform our culture
apart from having a profound impact on
the indian economy
this is about something much bigger
as
you all know when we
move
we can be seen
the more women see other women in public
spaces the more safe
independent and empowered each one of us
will be
so
if we can learn how to walk
certainly we can learn how to fly
thank you
you